now I've been on this [ __ ] as a business  strategy my whole [ __ ] life  but now that we're talking about being  good for your health like  we need to really lean in fam like  Community it's time like I've been  against pessimism and cynicism forever  I've always seen it heavily affect  negatively friends family business  associates  but if there's ever been a time to  really start understanding optimism it's  now it's deeply real life is how you see  it if you decide everything's [ __ ] guess  what it's [ __ ] and if you decide  everything's good guess what it's good  but if science keeps getting more  complicated and understanding  the fact that this is talking about like  your actual Health like living longer  please choose optimism in 2023 who's  with me